assistant
I don't know what that is what is it
the delicate balance of the entire solar
system exists in a gravitational dance
between planets
swap the orbits of two of them and you
could end up wreaking all kinds of havoc
what would happen to a rocky red planet
stuck between two gas giants
how would Earth react to a gigantic new
neighbor
and why would a big shift in gravity
trigger an asteroid apocalypse
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter and Mars switched
orbits
the Sun and Jupiter are the two largest
objects in our solar system
the gravitational forces of these
behemoths influence each other's
movements and they have a big impact on
the movement of all the other planets
moons and asteroids in our Cosmic
neighborhood
on the inner side of this belt is the
fourth planet from the sun and our
neighbor Mars
the red planet is located a mere 78
million kilometers from Earth that means
it's eight times closer to us than
Jupiter is
Jupiter is the fifth planet from the sun
located at a distance of about
778 million kilometers away and it's the
gas giants tremendous force of gravity
that could be responsible for the
asteroid belt separating the inner and
outer regions of the solar system
so if these two planets suddenly swapped
orbits would the millions of Rocky
objects in the asteroid belt come flying
right at us
these threats overhead would be
terrifying but at least we'd see them
coming you know sometimes life throws
things at you that you're not prepared
to take on according to a survey in 2022
56 percent of Americans can't cover an
unexpected bill of one thousand dollars
or more yeah so a car problem or a
health issue could send people into
severe debt so how do we solve this
problem well maybe we should give people
what they need cash
support goes a long way to helping our
neighbors survive day to day because it
gives them the tools they need to solve
their problems without judgment or
conditions for assistance you know we
accept social security and disability
programs but we need new solutions to
address the growing income inequality in
our society it's time to provide a
different safety net for low to moderate
income workers and families let's urge
lawmakers to use the tax code to help
our citizens so that they're ready to
act when the unexpected strikes when we
provide the tools people need to survive
the outcome is better for all of us
let's start by checking out how Mars
would fare in this orbital Switcheroo it
would now be jammed between the gas
giants Jupiter and Saturn this would put
the red planet in the uncomfortable
position of having the two biggest
planets in the solar system on either
side of it it would be uncomfortable
because of those gas giants
gravitational pull
but the pull would be uneven and Mars
would suffer a similar fate to that of
one of Jupiter's moons I'll
like IO Mars would experience a stronger
attraction on the side facing Jupiter
compared to the side facing away
this would stretch and compress the
rocky planet
Mars would start to heat up from the
inside
that's the reason IO is plagued by more
active volcanic eruptions than anywhere
else in the solar system Place Mars in a
similar game of tug-of-war and the
gravitational forces could be strong
enough to reactivate a few of its own
ancient volcanoes
yeah you could end up seeing lava
erupting out of Olympus Mons the biggest
volcano in the solar system
okay now hopping back over to our side
of the asteroid belt things would be
getting interesting here on Earth
the first big change you'd notice would
be the night sky being a little
different
yeah Jupiter would go from appearing as
a distant bright star to being about 20
percent as large as the Moon
looking up on a clear night you could
see its colorful bands and spots but not
everything would be swirly and pretty
in its new real estate right next door
Jupiter's gravitational impact on Earth
would be about 64 times stronger than it
is now
you know Jupiter already impacts Us From
a Distance every 405
000 years its pull along with venuses is
responsible for droughts and intense
rain
with it being this close the effect
would be more extreme and the
consequences deadly
caught between the Sun and Jupiter our
planet would experience cataclysmic
problems with tidal bulging
so what you once knew as a lovely
habitable home would transition into a
volcanic hell
and that wouldn't be the Only Hell
Unleashed with Jupiter suddenly on the
opposite side of the asteroid belt all
those millions of rocks would be pulled
in New Directions toward it
and that would set more than a few on a
crash course with Earth
the objects in the asteroid belt range
in size on the massive size there's the
dwarf planet series
it's about 25 percent the size of our
moon and of the asteroids Vesta is an
unwieldedly
530 kilometers across
but an asteroid wouldn't even need to be
anywhere near that large to hit Earth
and Trigger the Apocalypse
a collision with one as small as one
kilometer could be the end for us
if an asteroid about 10 kilometers
across crashed into our planet it would
result in the sun being blocked out for
a year or more
and without sunlight we'd experience
what's known as impact winter
temperatures would drop and
photosynthesis would stop this would
lead to the mass extinction of plant
animal and human life
thanks Jupiter
but at least the largest asteroid didn't
collide with Earth
yet
well get your bunker ready because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]